if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it once you believe
it you act like it
didn't call on anybody for a year
because i was literally
frozen in fear if you're nervous
learn to listen better and learn to ask
questions
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the habits
that will make you more confident and
outgoing even if you are a shy person
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one become someone else with tony
robbins
i'm very shy so it's hard for me to make
friends and get noticed at work
how can i change that uh come naked to
work
that'll change it very quickly i would
say
first of all all of us have
kind of an identity for ourselves a way
of defining ourselves
and human beings don't usually stray
from that so if you consider yourself to
be a conservative person or a shy person
i know the way you move to some extent i
know the facial expressions the gestures
the way you use your body
and it's all consistent with the fact
that human beings
our strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
if your self-definition is uh i'm a
situation where i'm kind of
what was the word he used shy shy then
you're going to find a way to get to a
place where you kind of cower back
right the fastest thing you could do to
change your experience would be to
create a new little thing a simple thing
like erase the menu i'm shy go erase
that's a bs story bs meaning uh belief
system
now that that's just a story and if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it once you believe it
you act like it
when you calling yourself shy you
believe it you're 20 i've always been
shot
up until this moment do something that's
completely outside
what you would normally do something
become somebody else decide who's the
most playful
passionate outrageous fun person you
know and behave like them for two or
three days
just push yourself to behave like that
here's what's happened it'll be shocking
you'll be weird you'll be different
you'll feel uncomfortable
but after a while you'll get reinforced
it's like if you get a nice haircut you
get you make a change in the way you
look
people will compliment you you'll get
some compliments and those compliments
will make you want to use those other
parts yourself
habit number two practice with jordan
peterson
what is your advice for people that
aren't very social and have a hard time
making friends
get the hell out there and practice man
i had a client
very introverted very introverted person
very badly served by her parents
not very well socialized extremely
socially anxious
awkward in her social interactions as
well so not skilled
um she does and also alone she didn't
have an intimate relationship or
really any family so quite quite
isolated person and terrified of social
interactions like she couldn't even
go out and have a coffee with me as her
therapist
as a practice exercise when we first met
and man
she's made progress like you wouldn't
believe to terror unbelievable progress
um you know doing public doing public
appearances on stage even
um go go take uh go to toastmasters
do some public speaking uh
join meetup.com um
ask people questions you know that's a
really good thing if you're not very
social
and and you get self-conscious you start
thinking about yourself and how stupid
you are that's a really bad idea
you should be paying attention to the
other person so if you get
nervous it isn't that you have to stop
being nervous because that isn't going
to work what you have to do is start
paying more attention to the other
person you have to force your attention
outward and you know you can ask people
questions listen to them
and when they say something interesting
or they say something you don't
understand
ask them a question and people love that
man because
they know you're listening to them and
people love being listened to
so if you're nervous learn to listen
better and learn to ask questions and
and there's no stupid questions
if you're paying attention right and so
you don't have to worry about that
if you don't know something if you don't
know something and you ask an
honest question and someone treats you
badly because of it then you should just
go away from that person because they
don't have a clue
so get out there
forget about trying to not be nervous
because you're going to be nervous but
when you're nervous pay more
attention to other people listen to them
carefully
watch them because then your natural
social abilities will kick in
and ask them questions and you know
you'll
assume it'll take you three or four
years to get decently good at it and
that you'll really have to work at it
but it's worth it man so so just go out
there and and do it
habit number three is be courageous with
grant cardone
i remember being 25 years old scared the
death
of people 29 years old started my
speaking career
terrified of the people i had to go to
didn't call on anybody for a year
because i was literally
frozen in fear and one day said somebody
said something to me do you
need you need to handle your
self-confidence issue
so i went and bought a suit and i didn't
feel any better i went bought a car
didn't feel any better about myself i
mean i felt a little better for a second
look self-confidence is the only outfit
you can't buy
this is an inside job you got to study
you got to learn you got to practice and
you have to
you have to do the hard things
self-confidence comes from
repeating experiences that are difficult
same place courage comes from
you know the guy that does something
that's courageous is given the title of
being
courageous it's not because he went in
war
courageous it's because he went and did
something look if you want to build
self-confidence
you can listen to the subliminal tapes
it's not going to work
you can go do hypnotism it's freaking
ridiculous you need to be more aware
more alert and you need to do more
some of the ideas that people are
throwing at you guys right now to build
your self-confidence you're going to eat
different and feel better
you're going to do this and feel look
you need to get in front of people do
the things you're scared to do
to get the self-confidence you want to
have period
it's not on sale it's not at
bloomingdale's macy's it's not a toyota
it's not on the radio dude it's an
inside job i can't help you with it
you got to take what i'm giving you in
these blurbs
blabs streams scopes cats whatever
you're calling it the posts the streams
the instagrams hey man i need to take
that
and start applying it in my life
otherwise you're going to find yourself
feeling worse and worse and worse about
yourself you want to go walk on fire
go do it is that going to build your
self-confidence i doubt it
okay i doubt it man go spend eight grand
on a weekend
that will not improve your
self-confidence the only thing i know
for sure that will change your sense of
self
is the actions you take getting in front
of other people
other people people you don't know
people you're scared to talk to
you're sitting there trembling through
your pitch until you don't tremble
anymore
self-confidence an inside job it's not a
suit you put on it's not a car you drive
this is not something you buy this is
something you develop hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number four is stop
self-obsession with russell brand
shyness
shyness is interesting someone told me
that shyness is self-obsession
but passive self-obsession that when i'm
feeling shy about oh no i'm all shy
about going here it's really because i'm
so self-obsessed
if i stop being self-obsessed i won't
feel so shy
of course insecurity insecurity and
inadequacy play their role in shyness
but if you're not self-obsessed you
won't care what other people are
thinking and then you will not feel so
shy
shyness is you know a charming
quality in some respects if it's
you know diffidence a kind of a gentle
humility
self-obsession though never really take
us anywhere useful
believe me i know i've done my time on
the self-obsession front and i still
like to do it as a hobby
shyness i do think is oh i'm going in
let's say i feel shy going to a big
party where i think there's gonna be
lots of famous people there because i
did go to one
and uh when i analyzed it because of
course i analyzed it i hate the idea
that there's stuff going to work in my
consciousness i don't even understand
what it is i mean the
biochemical activity that i won't
understand because my consciousness
isn't
evolved enough to sort of
cannibalistically flick back and observe
itself but
generally speaking nice thing why do you
feel shy and i realized oh it's because
there's gonna be other famous people
there and you're sort of shy about where
you fit into in some imagined hierarchy
of famous people
whether or not you're the right type of
famous you know whether or not you've
done enough to be sort of credible and
you know the ego man it's always finding
a way
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is get out of your comfort zone with dan
lok how do you become
an extrovert when you are actually an
introvert
now i am actually an ambivert what it
means is i'm actually
introvert by nature that like to be by
myself
but i could be an extrovert at certain
times
in an environment that i'm comfortable
with now i know it's hard to believe
when you watch my videos all the time on
on social media and you know that i
speak to large
groups of people but in private i'm
actually
uh quite introvert that i like i like my
own space
that i don't i like not to be bothered
right so that's introvert however over
the years i've learned
that just by being introvert in certain
areas
especially when it comes to business
that holds me back
the reason is in business it requires
you to talk to people
right imagine when you are growing up
think about it
when you're growing up what did your
parents tell you
don't talk to strangers right you're
going to get kidnapped
right you're gonna you're gonna be
they're gonna do something harmful to
you
right so it's always growing up you you
have this fear you develop this fear of
oh i don't want to talk to to strangers
it's very scary it's very very dangerous
well guess what after now you're an
adult when you're out there in the real
world
if you don't talk to strangers you're
broke in fact i say the amount of
success the amount of money is in direct
proportion
to how many strangers that you talk to
every single day
because in business what is it all about
it is about getting attention
number one after getting attention is
turning a stranger
into a friend turning a friend into a
customer in their customer
to a raving fan that's what business is
all about
that's what sales is all about it's
pretty simple so if you're not talking
to strangers
you're not making more money you cannot
be making more money
marketing is putting your offer putting
your story putting your product
in front of people that who didn't know
you before they've never heard of you
before
that's called marketing who are these
people they're all
strangers so that's what i'm talking
about so you got to be comfortable so
a few things that i did number one
as an introvert i joined toastmasters i
learned
how to speak in public to get out of my
comfort zone so that i can
be a little bit more comfortable talking
to people i forced
i forced myself to go to networking
functions to go to business functions
to talk to people to learn to ask
questions even though it was
uncomfortable but i knew i need to get
out of my comfort zone
so now through training and through
conditioning that i
could be an extrovert when necessary
now most of the time i'm still very
private right i could be in my room just
thinking and doing and brainstorming
and reading whole day and not talking to
a single person the whole day
and i'm very comfortable with just being
by myself
or i could go out there and i could talk
to a huge group of audience or even
connecting with you on social media
i'm perfectly okay as well so it's
trained
don't feel like oh this is who i am yes
by nature you're naturally more maybe
more like an introvert
but through time through skills through
training
you could expand your comfort zone
because think about how many
opportunities
comment below you're missing because
you're shy
because you don't want to talk to people
because you don't want to talk to
strangers
you're afraid to present you're afraid
to articulate your ideas you're free to
communicate
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and how are you going to take action on
it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time in what place you're going to
take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just
a 35 chance if you just got motivated
but never created a specific plan and
when you share your plan publicly and
have some accountability you
increase your chances even further of
actually following through
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway and your plan of action this
week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
rejection leads to success all you have
to do is look at the people that you
look up to look at the people that are
profiled on my youtube channels and what
you'll find
is rejection after rejection after
rejection
so rejection leads to success you know
this intellectually you
already know this but when you get into
the situation where you have to face
rejection
then your emotions take over your fears
take over and you don't
do the thing that you might get rejected
for even though you know
logically because in that moment your
emotions your fear
are greater than your logic i had a
life-changing fear of rejection
situation happened to me
in paris when i was 18 years old
and i was there when i was on the street
outside the notre dame cathedral and i
had a map
in front of me and this cute girl comes
up to me she asks for directions
and i wanted to ask her out and i was
too afraid i was too embarrassed
i was too ashamed i was too worried that
i might get rejected
in my head the only thing to think of
was i want to ask her out
and she might reject me she might say no
and so what did i do nothing now
if i had logically stood to the side
press timeout you know pause the
situation say evan
logically what makes sense logically you
know she might say no
and you're okay you'll move on with the
rest of your day logically she might say
yes why is why is she coming up to you
asking for directions why is she asking
for directions when
she already speaks perfect french and
she seems like a local
right logically that's what makes the
most sense
logically i should have summoned the
courage to go off and do it
but in the moment your emotions take
over your fear takes over
that idea that you might get rejected
takes over and so what did i do
nothing i let her walk away
and ever since that day i reminded
myself that
i would rather know and fail than not
know
and i use that painful moment to
whenever i am thinking about
doing something i'm afraid of rejection
for afraid of it not working out
then i have to do it that that moment is
what led me to become an entrepreneur
because a year later when i had the
chance to have my dream job and make
100k a year
travel around the world or be an
entrepreneur on 30 of a business and
make 300
a month i had that picture in my head
where i was thinking i can't let this
happen again i don't want to live with
regret i would rather know and fail than
not know
and that gave me the courage to keep
going
so i know you guys know this i know you
know it intellectually i know every
success story that you read is
motivating as inspiring to you and you
see all the rejections
but then when you get faced with it when
you're face to face
with that fear tend to play small
you tend to do the thing that you're not
proud of and then you tend to live with
regret
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
to learn
powerful ways to build self-confidence
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there